smoke billowing towards the Australian
capital Canberra bush fires in a
national park to the south post the most
serious threat to the Australian Capital
Territory or a city in nearly 20 years
government officials fear that strong
winds blowing over parched land combined
with high summer temperatures can make
the fires even more unpredictable and
difficult to control the ICT is now
facing the worst bushfire threat since
the devastating fires of 2003 the
combination of extreme heat wind and a
dry landscape will play suburbs in
Canberra South at risk in the coming
days the auroral fire has now grown to
eighteen and a half thousand hectares
that's a hundred and eighty-five square
kilometres or nearly eight percent of
the total landmass of the Australian
Capital Territory people preparing for
the worst and stocking up on water many
remember the 2003 bush fires that killed
four people the irken bura and destroyed
hundreds of homes I'm concerned that the
AC T does not have the ability to put a
fire out no attention given to it and
then the unpredictable weather through
the summer has made the fight more
difficult this video shows how bush
fires have exploded in minutes because
of sudden gusts of wind about 90 bush
fires are burning in different parts of
the country the largest are New South
Wales where high temperatures are
returning back in the 40s in the next 24
hours the fire threatening Canberra is
also moving towards New South Wales the
state's government is investigating why
this fire season is so bad we've got
everything to gain from this process and
nothing to lose we won't leave any stone
unturned it's in our interest it's in
our citizens in
to find out everything we can and to and
to bring forward those recommendations
that are critical for the future this
has been Australia's most devastating
summer in decades dozens of people have
been killed by the fires thousands of
homes have been destroyed and more than
11 million hectares of land scorched and
with some are far from over
there are many more testing days ahead
Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera